you're working on this show city on a
hill yeah and it takes place in Boston
it does which is my hometown I realize
this so my first question is are they
taking care of you
yes when you when the times you've been
there for shooting you know you don't do
all the shooting there yeah no I I love
working in Boston
coincidentally this is like the sixth
thing I've done there I did Mystic River
and I know you've done so many yes
you've done so many things that take
place and a lot of stuff yeah and so you
know I've also been in Boston the FBI
this is my third Boston FBI guy Eve so
even they there's even like that you
know so you're getting typecast yes and
you're not from boss not profound
fulfilling no so and but nothing ever
like things unfortunately you know bah
it's good for Boston but you know feel
affiliated that people don't set things
in Philly that often so sorry right they
need to yeah there needs to be a guy
that me a guy who's like guarding the
Liberty Bell yeah exactly exactly good
rock or what Rocky was enough yeah you
hardened that Liberty Bell I'll tell
myself oh yeah what what kind of coke
diet coke every week they've stolen the
Liberty Bell and you have to get it back
hey from that Liberty Bell there's
already one crack uni I don't know so
you got that obviously you've got that
that you have the do you have the
because the Boston accent is so hard
it's hard it's really hard to do it some
people focus in there's some actors who
famously they do movie and bus let's say
I'm gonna try it yes like yes I try it
you try it yeah no but you do it you you
do a pretty good job thank you thank you
yeah you very good job well you know I
do my best the one thing I know for sure
is that nobody from Boston is gonna like
my Boston accent people from Boston
don't even like it when a guy from
Boston does a Boston accent no you know
people from Boston almost in a weird way
root against people from Boston who've
left Boston they're like would you leave
Boston for you like because I went out
into the world I still come back here
all the time you know I've just resigned
myself to that
and I find that I try to think of it
listen you know what I always think
about is it you remember Car Talk yeah
was on NPR was a great for those you
don't remember is like a great the great
showed these two brothers right and and
and they would just sit around they talk
about cars is hilarious and stuff and
but when you really analyze their two
accents they sounded very very different
yeah and there were two guys that were
raised in exactly the same household so
it just goes to show you that you know
from one side of town to the other
there's no there's no absolutely this is
what I keep telling myself I am I am one
of six kids raised in Boston I don't
understand anything any of them are
saying what's your favorite word to say
in a Boston accent I'd say that scene
doesn't call for that word that word has
a certain zing in any dialect though you
know I'm sorry in Britain that kind of
leapt out of my mouth I didn't really
think about it's alright it's alright
you know so it's primarily for children
but this whole audience is on work
release yeah good but you know it's
interesting because I my character
curses a lot so I get to say that along
with pretty much every other curse
possible and curses do work great in a
Boston my accent and but the other day
the that came to me in the post
production and they said listen we need
to clean this up for the foreign markets
and let me tell you that was a lot of
work I'm on we've done ten episodes I'm
on Episode eight now and it's probably
in the course of one episode I probably
have 50 lines that I have to change and
the things that they come up with
to replace him you know is just they're
hilarious
I mean I'm trying to even think of oh
gosh watch it yeah exactly yeah yeah
it's like when you watch if you ever
watch Goodfellas on on network
television it's ridiculous yeah
Joe Pesci alone just watch wait look at
your TV you know I said look at your TV
Guide that said them and then sign up to
fight the Civil War you can ever see a
showing of Goodfellas on like ABC at 8
o'clock at night it's all Joe Pesci
going like you bunny hump up